that's my secret I'm not just totally
not Mark AKA Mark Fitzpatrick anymore I
am multiple people I
am the entire universe no but actually
I'm always amused at how often internet
folks don't seem to realize that just
about every piece of media they consume
is made by an entire team sometimes I'll
see people talking about a creative
Direction in a TV show and ask why did
Netflix or whatever Studio do that let
me let you in on a small secret almost
everything you watch is created by a
combined effort of many people from the
obvious team efforts like blockbuster
movies to TV shows and the highly
collaborative writing rooms all the way
down to measly YouTubers and Tik tokers
such as myself hell the same goes for
even these little short videos that
you're watching right now that I do
depending on the video any combination
of myself my Tik Tok writer Tyson my
other writer AJ and so on may have
written what ends up on your screen
their interests are my interests and I
am the product of many pasteurization is
the product of temperature and time